are we rocking okay oh
it set that up
okay i'm iman shuffle
nba champion husband father
lyricist you see me getting my fists off
in that nba tunnel
but now i'm the drift director well
welcome back for another episode of drip
director
of course myself iman uh we have rox
brown
i apologize i don't have the green when
i'm at shooting but
what kind of bottoms you got on i didn't
really make sense
all right all right rocks you ready
today i'm going to be stalling a cool
couple
corey wash and mellow x melo is a
talented songwriter producer
corey is a model and visual artist they
already have their own pretty cool
eclectic style so today i'm just going
to be suggesting some pieces
hi i'm corey wash how are you doing on
mellow x
three words to describe my current style
[Music]
one word is moody another word is
comfortable
and extra
three words to describe my current style
first word that comes to mind
and then i would say i gotta say
the last would be random
you know because every now and then um i
find that pieces just like
sticks out from anything else i wear if
i had to throw in just like a bonus word
for you it would be
brooklyn
we're excited to have you guys i love
the earthy vibes like the braids i love
that i love that it works
thanks for having us i'm gonna throw it
back to you rox and let me know what
everybody's wearing and how it works
i think that melo and cory have great
individual styles
so first you know we got a lot of cozy
hoodies as you know we're in quarantine
which is why
we're doing this over some i'm wearing
like good before screen
but for you guys um you know i have
i know you guys have a child and you
know it's a lot of running around and
taking care of kids
corey just tell me a little bit of what
your day-to-day looks like
chasing your toddler around i wake up
about an hour
after these two i'm usually wearing a
hoodie
some type of like oversized t-shirts i'm
usually in the morning i'm like
as comfortable as i can be that's
perfect those are the kind of pieces i
have
for you today it's like got a sweatsuit
[ __ ] spicy vibe going on posing
vibing you have to run out you know take
the baby to the park or something
i got this good jacket for you but you
know i will let you put it on the way
you put it on
yeah for sure all right so i'm gonna get
dressed i said you wake up
uh what what's early like 6 a.m
being a parent of a toddler affects your
style like
yeah definitely dad lives you know gotta
find that hoodie i can wear every day
you know i'm saying i'm bad
[Music]
oh this one right here
i feel like you know like the jogging
suit is like good you know you could
get up out of bed you could walk around
the house and that and like when it's
time to go outside
you just throw the jacket on and it
makes it a whole look yeah
i'll probably throw some shades on or
like a cowboy hat
just like cowboy hats where you from i'm
from baltimore actually
yeah but i just where let's come from
what trip did you want to say tell me
the story where
you start like a cowboy i didn't know
that i liked cowboy hats
but he had one laying around and i was
like let me just try this one
and then i instantly felt like a chief i
felt like the man
in charge around these parts you know
what i'm saying
but not and then i just started going to
thrift stores and then i would just see
the cowboy hat you could you know add
your own personal flavor to it with the
cowboy hat
[Music]
for for you mello i got like something
similar
to corey's look but i got like this
yeah you all a couple man you got a
match you gotta match a little bit so i
got like this
you know kind of like tan i guess i
would call it
kind of the same color that mine has on
me you look like a team it's cool
and i also have these joggers they're
not really sweating they're kind of like
pants so they're like
joggers but they still got the like
scrunchy bottoms and the
you know the adjustable waistband and
i'm appearing with some like cool socks
so you could chill and help i'll be
running through socks so i need like 10
you don't know socks just disappear all
the time
i don't know my toes run through the
socks
why literally really i need like
five minutes what is something that you
hate in his closet
oh oh my gosh she had this really bad
um hoodie it had this like huge mesh
like
kangaroo pouch and he would literally
put like everything he would put his
life in there
i was like his thing too so that was his
thing he would just be like cool with my
hoodie
and i'm like yo
so
[Music]
feeling quarantined cozy in your fit
mellow i thought you might be a little
tight
for me when he's like a little oversized
the socks though
look he all needs sucks
you'll get the sun yo he's trying to get
a care package
right
i feel like those are just like easy
things that you know you could put
together
i would like to see with you guys like
you know just go on a rack
and put together what you want to put
together so i can see how you style it
this thing y'all about to pull up y'all
outside you know what i'm saying
it's like my everyday life you seem
comfortable in there
it's like that that's that logo is like
nostalgic like
i remember i had to have yeah i had the
gap logo on
all of my stuff
you ready hello the thing is that these
look supposed to be versatile so this is
the look you take this is camping this
is the store run real quick
you know what i'm saying go outside for
a walk with my son
[Music]
so that's like the good thing about like
all like these like gap hoodies and
stuff like that yeah everything's
comfortable
it's all stay in your hair because it
got real pastel in it
how's the match
oh now we're the power in what you're
supposed to be see wow
how do i get
[Laughter]
these socks man
now y'all got the entire you know
holiday gap collection you got the
collection of cozy hoodies if you want
to stay in the house
you know how to make it versatile today
you can throw a flannel over a jacket
throw a chain on a beanie on and mine
and that led you in the right direction
to mind how you feeling
any way you pick today has you set for
anything
that you have today whether it be taking
care of the kid
whether it's leaving now to go to the
studio
uh both of your respective studio spaces
i'm glad i got you some socks
mellow we try to flood the crib with
soccer
i just want to thank you all for coming
over thanks for having us
[Music]
okay
happy holidays y'all happy holidays
happy holidays come on yes okay
now i feel like bring the energy with
the happy holidays